he said so when i
started bitcoin bitcoin was 100 almost
exactly
and what 2012 2013 okay i
i was gonna start mining in 2012 fall
2012
but um
here i'll talk about the arms race a
little with mining it was a little
rabbit hole
um when bitcoin
i told you earlier that litecoin was is
just a tweak of the bitcoin network it
changed the block
time what that means is that
um the the network targets
for a new block to be found about every
10 minutes for bitcoin
but there's not like a hard it's not
like a hard um
it's not like this happens every 10
minutes it's a target it's how fast the
computers can do it right
exactly so a lot of times what happens
is
a computer will get lucky and it'll find
it in two minutes or something
you know and and so over the course of
two weeks
it once it checks to see if the average
is ten minutes
and if it's not what it'll do is it'll
either make the puzzle harder or so
or or easier depending to make it 10
minutes so if
and pretty much all the time it's always
been getting harder
because computers are getting faster and
faster and able to find it faster and
faster so
if you so the faster the computers are
the
more height like the more complex
they're encrypted the the harder the if
you want to think about this way
the bigger the haystack gets right for
finding the need on the haystack
right so if you get a machine if you
imagine this machine that gets
it's it's it's kind of good at finding
needles in a haystack and you know you
have a little small haystack it'll take
it 10 minutes
and it'll find it but if you have this
like industrial
hay sorter machine that can just
gobble that through that two seconds
right and find the needle then
it just needs to make a bigger stack so
it started off
you could just mine bitcoin on on your
laptop like anybody could mine it
um but then people figured out that if
you used
gpus graphic graphic processing units
like video cards uh you could get pretty
efficient
performance and it was like a order of
magnitude better
at solving the puzzle and so then people
who had cpu you know just doing it with
their laptops
weren't really able to do it anymore
because the the gpus were so good
at it that that the the algorithm had to
make it harder
so like if you had your little cpu you
know it'd be like
one guy looking at this giant haystack
you know uh
to go through and and he wouldn't be
able to but if you had the gpu it could
power through it and do it in 10 minutes
and then um
what came out next was fpgas field
programmable gated arrays
field programmable gate arrays anyhow um
and those uh those lasted a little while
they're basically just uh
like uh highly adaptable programmable
circuits you can
you can sort of specialize things for um
so they're very good like specialist
chips you can program to do all they're
used in all kinds of industries for all
kinds of things
but then shortly after those came out
the asics came out
application specific integrated circuits
basically these are
cpus that are designed to do just one
thing and they're designed to do them
really well
special built custom built and
these are supposed to come out in like
the fall of 2012
and there's this one company that was
developing them or putting them out
called butterfly labs
i almost hate to give them a plug
because it they ended up being huge
scammers but
um they're not around anymore so it's
not a big deal
but so in fall of 2012 when i was
looking getting into mining i was going
to get some gpus
and build some computers and whatever
but these butterfly labs guys have built
all these
or i put out all these google ads like i
don't know how much they paid on google
ads but literally anytime i searched
for anything uh you know bitcoin mining
related their ads are everywhere
and these asics were like an order of
magnitude
more efficient than the gpus so i'm like
looking at all these profitability
calculators okay if i buy
this gpu you know it'll pay for itself
in like a year
or something like that and then you're
looking then this ad pops up and you're
like oh my god
if this thing comes out it would pay for
itself in like three days
you know you pay a thousand dollars for
it or 500 for it and then
it's so fast that in three days of
mining bitcoin you would get
500 worth of bitcoin uh but then they
just
so i was like well i'm just i'll just
wait until they come out and there's no
point in getting
my gpu gear ready and so
but then they didn't come out they
didn't come out and come out and then it
was like 2013
uh they still hadn't come out or they
well they still hadn't been delivered
um they were out there it turned out
that what butterfly labs was doing is
yeah of course like if they have the
heart it's like the cantillian effect i
was talking about with
the person that has the money first uh
so they had these miners that could
mine like ridiculously fast first like
they were the first guys they're like
well you know they'd have a burn-in
period
right where they're tested or something
right so they would run them
they would they would they were running
them at their facilities
and then uh that would cause the the
network hash rate to
go up a lot like that you know because
they were really powerful so
that meant that the the haystack was
getting bigger
and then once the haystack had gotten
big enough then they would send them to
the customers that paid for them
wow so they would make a ton of money oh
my god what a scam yeah and
basic companies still do it's still that
way that you need to be
whatever the next generation asic is the
closer you are to the
like the hardware manufacturer like
because literally
if you order one making a profit
it could like getting it next week
versus
the week after next could be the
difference between you breaking even and
making money or
you never really recouping because of
how fast they're advancing
well because of how it's not just the
advancement there's also
you know if you manufacture a bunch of
these like it's a
you know there's strength of numbers too
so the more you have looking right
the more odds there are that somebody's
going to get lucky and find it faster
you know right so they're mass producing
these things too
but that's that's why instead of getting
in in 2012 when
bitcoin was like 20 or 12 or something
like that i ended up getting in
finally i just it was march i think or
no
january february 2013 the price started
going up and i was like man i missed the
boat
i should have started i should have
started
mining i should have just said forget it
and bought the computers in mind and
and uh yeah i remember like
a year later after i'd been mining for a
while i remember i was looking i was
trying to
troubleshoot something and i looked
through this uh
i was looking through this forum and it
was a post from like yeah
mid late 2012 and this guy was like oh
guys i'm only me i've got this this gpu
which is the exact gpu i had
because i was trying to troubleshoot
that one gpu he's like oh there's one
i'm only getting one bitcoin a day what
am i doing wrong
one bitcoin a day yeah and and
and at that time that would have been a
fantastic return because
bitcoin was uh when i was reading it
bitcoin was like 200
and so that would have been like 200 a
day off that one little gpu if you'd
if you'd
you